[Musik]
wenn jonathan kreutner und sein vater
robert den film die akte grüninger
ansehen blicken sie auf ihre eigene
familiengeschichte
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ziemlich bewegen die bilder mich
natürlich schon sehr bewegend migros
ältere sehe eigentlich die ganze
geschichte so läuft mit salat mitschüler
[Musik]
jonathan kreutner dass großeltern kamen
1938 an die schweizer grenze
bitte lassen sie uns darüber was müssen
zwei sachen wo mich interessiert
sicherlich was ist genau passiert der
band nach der szene wohnung in großvater
zusammengeschlagen wurde nicht was ist
passiert was ich gesehen wie sehen sie
twitter und was ist der wahre grund am
schluss sie dass sie wirklich das
schwitzen können bliebe und und wer ihn
wirklich am schlusskurs für hat und wer
verantwortlich dafür dass ihnen keine
blieben schweiz robert kreutner war noch
ein kleines kind als seine eltern in der
nacht den alten rhein passierten
er selbst so erzählte es ihm seine
mutter hatte an diesem tag hohes fieber
seine familie stand kurz davor
aufzugeben
als sie von einem schweizer grenzwächter
angehalten burgen dass ich im november 8
uhr ist sie nach der kristallnacht womit
ihr großvater ebenfalls für den
großvater schwer verletzt worden ist am
29 november hat sie sich zur flucht
entschlossen sind mit dem zug bis auf
feldkirch ots und 31 ist an bord
versucht zum überreichen
das ist nicht erfreulich sagt sie bei
acht mal und am schluss stage mag sich
würde grenzach 3 gemacht hat dass sich
als rehn sehr groß schauen lernt gemacht
haben steht danach sehe mit dem grund
und hat da ist ein zeitmesser mit dem
mikro wenn mini motor ist der abstand im
wasser dass ich irgendwas hat sie seien
sie quasi auf erzählt hat und jetzt
kommt zurück
doch als ich versuche aber ich komme
immer zurück will war mit rückgang
erwartet weil das ganze an stationen
eisfelder konzentrationslager
grenzwächter eigenes vorgesetzter war
kommandant paul grüninger er half den
grenz gehirn und rettete so tausende
menschenleben
[Musik]
ich habe zwei funktionen für eine sitze
uncle von flüchtlingen und sohn
verflüchtigen wollte auch die ricoh sind
und gerettet worden sind und schloss auf
weniger und gleichzeitig bin ich zurzeit
generalsekretären schweizerische
israelitische gemeindebund wo damals
auch schon existiert hat während und vor
dem krieg und machen wirkt natürlich und
auch rolle gespielt hat natürlich der
flüchtlingsräte die frage ist eigentlich
offen welche rolle eigentlich nachher
vor allem schweizer gespielt haben
nach dem krieg also während nämlich
verschiedene eine ganze rühmliche rolle
sie weiß man nicht so genau aber
sicherlich nach dem krieg was ich so
weiß jetzt und so gehört das gefühl dass
man hätte ihm milch ernährt sollen die
heldentaten mich eine ehre
paul grüninger hat tochter wurden ua
protonen und sie hatten an konnte die
roten und ich glaube dir zwei bissen
sich bescheid wie sich der herr paul
grüninger nach dem krieg gefühlt hat
unmittelbar nach der vorteile die die
triste jahr gab sie wird sicher wissen
wie ihre laxe und sie werden vielleicht
erwische wäre ich sie unterstützt hat
und werne
was ist den großvater führung maxi also
wenn jetzt versucht es erinnere daran
ihren serien jeweils wirklich
menschliche großvater in real- oder
branche in echtzeit sich in eine ganze
haltung die flüchtlinge hat es ist es so
dass man natürlich nach so langer zeit
wie sehr in regen völlig normal denkt
denn es sind jetzt doch schon mehr als
40 jahre her
die geschichte hat ja ihren aufwand
knapp dazu kaufen was ihm aber zu haupt-
oder geschafft hat das ist starken
drucks iod und sein assistent frank und
sie ändert er nicht gewohnt
also geht's los auf der rechten seite im
haus zu moosburg
[Musik]
die flüchtlinge sind daher reuters
gebäude also ich gewusst dass die
großgeräte dem fahrrad
sie war schwierig sie sind ja den glaube
so viel wie margarine vom film
serientitel zur aufnahme aber noch wenn
sich amerika vorstellung wären und sie
sind sicher dürfen große ordentlich sich
patienten war riesig hinten getroffen
wurde dem büro dann richtig spannend
wenn man also geschwindner würdige
kulisse wert da das fußt auf der damals
stand sie
[Musik]
das ist ein risiko
doch herr wir gehwegs roadkill das ist
ein befehl
ob es wirklich wahrhaft ist der
momentane zugang aber am indischen
september wo das urteil fällt aber nicht
das endlos wird ein mann eben dazu
vertritt das büro verwirrt dass das ist
da wo ich mich erinnere
weißt du wenn er sich gefühlt hat er
jemals darüber geht doch relativ
niedrigen wenn man dann in den eigenen
auto zu ordnen dass sich die drei jungs
in uniform ab gehe also rein historische
degradiert sie und natürlich den platz
das bewusstsein
auch die dienstwohnung in der grüninger
samt familie lebte musste aufgegeben
werden wurde er von allen seiten fallen
gelassen
[Musik]
weißt du wie das vor offizieller
jüdischen six sigma nach der rezession
immer dahin können
wann hast du da nicht so sehr viel ich
war schon passiert die handeln also auch
ohne der im prozess die noch leben der
jüdischen flüchtlingen frage und sie
haben dann freilich auch seit sich hier
gezählt
nein nicht gewusst was mit polizei hat
man auch passiert ist aber ich denke
damit ich fürchte vom motto mal direkt
folge der werden aber wahr
[Musik]
roth roduner lebt heute in einem
altersheim in hamburg lange zeit war sie
selbst die treibende kraft hinter den
rehabilitierung versuchen für ihren
vater
darüber hinaus war es ruht die ihre
familie mit ihrer arbeit versorgen
konnte denn paul grüninger bekam als
verurteilter weder arbeit noch rente
[Musik]
und ihre ideen könntest du den
steinbruch geschafft aber wenigstens ihr
wolle bestellt hat kann also 120 franken
im monat haben einen betrieb führt
lehrer aber es ist also schon sehr wenig
sie will tony nominiert oder sind die
messe nutzen ist der wird die entstehung
von planeten doch frank rost im monat
und die haare und dazu inspirieren
also und theatern verdient also die wahl
sagen über meine verspätung mal gesagt
wir haben das auch gemacht und auch hans
in andere liegt unterstützt und ist
überhaupt jemand unterstützt überhaupt
niemand auch juden oder not als süße
dass wir jetzt hier sehr ambivalent und
den ns armin vater sehen
das sind da die einzige wo wenn es auch
wieder gut wie kein zimmer bis helfen
oder was noch klasse haben taktisch hat
dass man schon damals dass es gerade die
sechziger vor von einer rehabilitierung
gerät hat sie da wohl begrüßt zumal ich
auch mit gewissem sinn hat die auf
verschiedene vorstöße gemacht waren oder
aber wir sehen die immer abgelehnt war
ja oder weiß nicht wieviel oder mit dem
ak selbst casio dass das existiert die
möglichkeit im kanton st gallen gesetz
oder so dass man doch irgendwie notruf
zurück und weist als einfach alles reden
kann
[Musik]
es gab aber auch immer wieder menschen
die gerechtigkeit für paul grüninger
forderte allen voran stefan keller und
ständerat paul rechsteiner am
kreisgericht st gallen an dem grüninger
1940 verurteilt wurde
sollte der fall neu aufgerollt werden
[Musik]
regiere das behauptete lang alle
klinischen studie die rechnet martin und
mache es so dass noch halten durch die
damalige zu stellen können und das
verhalten damals und das ist abgelehnt
war das ist es baustelle aktiv um ihrem
großen 25 jahre später durch inzwischen
bereits im nationalpark sie unter
unseren galler kantonsrat hans fässler
verfolgter gescheitert aber dazu seiten
immerhin resultiert gründig vom verein
gerechtigkeit normal grüninger
[Musik]
erst 1995 wurde paul grüninger hier
posthum in einem feierlichen prozess
freigesprochen
[Musik]
einerseits scheint klar dass tweets und
unter armut und nach dem krieg sind in
grüningen danke sich unterstützen und
ins hilfe verstanden und zwar aufgrund
von politischer finanziellen druck und
ich glaube auch immer alles irgendwie
mit historische begebenheit wäre es
bliebt menschlich nicht ganz
verständlich
[Musik]
auch für die tatenlosigkeit des scg des
schweizerischen israelitischen
gemeindebundes bleibt das unverständnis
[Musik]
es ist auch verständlich auch nicht also
heutiger sicht hat es überhaupt nicht
verstehen will ich einfach nach dem
krieg nur caravelle handwerk und
flüchtlinge und ein holocaust dann
können und ich habe auch oft zukunft
ausrichten und fünfziger sechziger seit
ich das für mich gestört hätte man
damals gelebt werden auch nicht anders
sieht dies nicht verstehen dass man der
gerd hat das marien in einer google hat
aber wirtschaftlich finanziell einfach
nicht nur unbedeutend worden und es wäre
sicher ob sie für die gemeinschaft und
für ihn und einfluss haben in der
schweiz wahr machen die personalpolitik
[Musik]
spielte da vielleicht auch das gerücht
eine rolle grünen er selbst wäre ein
nazi sympathisant gewesen
also ich halte überhaupt nichts von der
küche und ich glaube alle vorgänge
handeln abhalten
tatsache ist dass es viele seriöse
historiker grüninger recherchiert hat
und schreibe hand und keiner hat das
überhaupt je wieder unterbricht
wenn super geht wo weiß wie sich der sek
sachsen 40 bis 70 mit dem grüninger
auseinandergesetzt hat oder nicht
auseinandergesetzt hat er nicht dass an
ein haus ist journalistin die kontakte
aus der zeit von mäßiger wahrscheinlich
sehr sehr gut da einiges nach
[Musik]
so
irgendwo hier ist das viel
was ist
[Musik]
entsprechend gut aus hier
im jahr 20 stehen november 18.30
schwimmt die del bonis eigentlich und
diepoldsau das ist ja das ist ja hoch
interessant auch die ganze akten
ableiten aber glaubt jetzt gesicht das
ist schon bewundert jetzt gerade hängen
ja ja das ist genau meine großeltern
sind ja hauptsächlich hat blieb vakant
paul grüninger was gibt es eigentlich
viel dokument zum paul grüninger nach
dem spiel gibt es dort bisher habt dann
müsst doch irgendwie oder oder über ja
nie einfach die akte grünen tisch
gesetzt auch relativ sparte und jetzt
sieht er aktivieren oder hast du alles
gefunden jetzt thema grüninger so jetzt
bezogen auf jüdische quälen das ist vor
allem den 60er jahre für den kanton st
gallen rehabilitiert werden ob ihre
habilitiert no teil wie es nach
moralischer sind aber nicht materiellen
grünen hat ja wärme bleibt in ihrer
epoche und man hat mindestens vorliegt
wo ihn kennt und im kosovo materiell
besser wenn der staat aber sich denn nie
so wie coco und der sg hat ist eine
auflage folgt worden ob er nach der
rehabilitation deren erste moralische
vom kanton st gallen auch ein stück weit
in grüningen geiger
interessanterweise nationalspieler
zeitig wie national tätig
geschafft innerhalb von einer woche eine
sammlung von 25 franken herz bringen
also es hat dann doch klappt dann klappt
das einfach bevölkerung wird sowohl
bereitschaft kam aber die
institutionellen vermisst
doch nico unter anderem schon mit
begründung oder rechtfertigung dass es
juristisch jetzt nicht möglich wäre
mit ihrer rehabilitation sich ein
besseres bringen sie mit den frauen
aspekt
[Musik]
wie kommen sie in die mitte wo sergio
mendoza bis vor zähle das filigrane
lösung die klinik jedoch macht in dieser
absoluten ihr sind und in zukunft haben
wir abgelehnt vom sg auf die zukunft aus
dem ihr euch gab es ist wichtig sich mir
vor allem wichtig sie nach dem wirklich
während zehn jahre eigentlich darüber
träger hat und eigentlich auch die
pfeiler 30 gemacht hat unmittelbar nach
dem krieg thematisiert hat von titanic
uns ist wichtig dass man dort zu
erstellen und das klassentreffen der
kreide zeigen da hat man also der
grüninger nach erklärt mit dem partner
und da vorne sind oma und opa batterie
oder generell davon
klar kann ich eigentlich aus der
geschichte machen alles historisch
erklären und es blieb einfach menschlich
gesehen eigentlich völlig unverständlich
und da wichtig ist und das sind ja ganz
entscheidend das defizit züge sind und
ihre geschichte und schicksal von danity
26 schicksal vom im pharmasektor
schicksal
foto rhode hier sind einzigartig
[Musik]
zwischen hält sie und als das muss man
natürlich auch in erinnerung walter und
möchte es auch nicht vergessen was er
hatte zwischen sich und der regen zulauf
der leiter der die dankbarkeit und die
erde nicht zuteil wirkung hat und ich
glaube es ist nicht spart ebenso
fragesteller es ist nicht spart sich
auseinandersetzen und das werden
sicherlich noch viel mehr machen
[Applaus]
natürlich nicht jeder kann ein held sein
aber sind wir mutig genug einen helden
als solchen auch zu erkennen
[Musik]
ende